let's say we have a magnetic field
that's coming out of the bright side of
the screen and it's it's not just along
the screen it's actually you know it's
three-dimensional and so it's it's going
above the screen below but it the the
direction of the magnetic field is from
the right to the left let me just draw
that and I'm not going to do it I'm not
going to draw a bunch of the field
vector arrows because that'll just take
up a lot of valuable space on our so
that's the vector magnetic field that's
down here too if I could I would draw it
above above your screen and below your
screen but is coming from the right to
the left and then in that magnetic field
I have an electric circuit and I won't
draw the whole circuit right now do that
in a second but let's say I have part of
the electric circuit is a loop and the
loop looks like this I'm trying to draw
it carefully so that we can because I
think a careful drawing will be more
useful in a second than an uncaring
drawing let's see so it's a loop you can
almost you can imagine taking a
paperclip and putting it into this shape
oh that's good enough I think and I have
a current going in this direction in
this paperclip so this is the positive
that's the negative so the current is
going like that current current is going
in a loop like that the currents coming
out of this end it's coming in to this
end so my and let's say that this this
loop of it could be a paperclip or
anything let's say that it can rotate
and that's important what's going to
happen well my magnetic field is coming
in this direction the current is going
down here up here what's going to be the
net force on the magnetic of the
magnetic field on on the sloop well
let's try it out and it turns out is
going to be a different magnitude at
different points of the current so here
and we don't worry about all we're
worried about right now is direction and
then maybe need a little intuition of
the magnitude so we know that the force
a magnetic field is equal to the current
times cause a length vector
cross the magnetic field right well what
would be what would be the force of the
magnetic field on this segment of wire
we could call this L right and that L
goes in the same direction as the
current let's see current is just a
scalar but L is going down magnetic
field is going to the left cross product
cross product I take my right hand put
my index finger I put my index finger in
the direction of the of the current or
in the direction of L because that's the
first term in the cross product that's
the index finger so my index finger goes
down because that's the direction of the
current and then my middle finger and
remember you have to do this with the
right hand if you do that the
left-hander getting out the opposite
result and now my middle finger is going
to go in the direction of the field so
let me point my middle finger my middle
finger is going to go in the direction
of the field I keep having to look at my
own hand and then my other two fingers
are just going to do what they need to
do so that's my third finger and that's
my pinky and then what is my thumb going
to do what is my thumb going to do well
my hand that's my hand this is kind of
this is what my hand is doing I'm
pointing downward right and my palm is
kind of pointing at my body so what is
my thumb doing if I know it's hard to
see this is this is my middle finger
right here so my thumb is on the other
side of this drawing and my thumb is
pointing downwards I hope you see that
all right and you try it with your own
hand so my thumb is pointing downward so
the direction of the force created by
the magnetic field on this current is
going to go downward so let me draw that
so the force vector then I'll do it in
this orange e brown color the force
vector on this segment of the wire is
going to be going down now what about
this segment of the wire well think
about it this segment of the wire the L
vector this L vector it's going it's
going well it's parallel to the magnetic
field just in the opposite direction
and so when you take the cross-product
if you remember the cross-product is
you're multiplying the magnitudes of the
vectors that are perpendicular to each
other but if this is the L vector right
here there's no component of it that
it's perpendicular to the magnetic field
so the magnetic field and then the
current will are in the same plane
they're parallel they're not orthogonal
at all there's no components of them
that are at 90 degrees so when you take
the cross-product you're going to see
that the net force on this segment of
the wire is zero and likewise on this
segment of the wire and this segment of
the wire because they aren't in any way
perpendicular no components of them are
even perpendicular so fair enough so all
we know right now is a magnetic field is
exerting a net downward force on this
side of our paperclip or of our circuit
now what about this side well same thing
take the cross-product if this is our L
L cross B so take your index finger in
the direction so index finger goes like
that your middle finger will go in the
direction of the field so your middle
finger is going to look something like
that
and then your other two fingers are
going to be like that and where's your
thumb going to do and this is has to be
a right hand to work your thumb is going
to point straight up this is like the
heel of your thumb and your thumb is
going to I don't know if that's a good
drawing of a thumb but your thumb is
essentially pointing out of the page
right middle finger in the direction of
the current or in the direction of our
length
oh sorry index finger in the direction
of current middle finger in the
direction of the field thumb points out
of the page and do that with your own
right hand and you'll see that the net
force of the magnetic field on this
segment of wire is going to be upwards
upwards let me do it in a different
color just to get some contrast going to
be upwards so what's going to happen
assuming that this circuit can rotate
what's going to happen on this side
where there's a downward force on this
side there's an upward force so the
magnetic field is actually exerting a
torque on this wire right it's exerting
a 4 like if you if you viewed if you
view this little dotted line as our axis
of rotation the whole coil is actually
going to rotate around that line and so
there's some force over here along the
whole line being applied downwards so
and it's actually perpendicular to our
moment arm if you remember what we had
learned about torque so it will actually
exert all of that force will be a you
know that force times this distance will
be the torque applied on this side and
then likewise there's an up there's a
torque in the it's really the same sign
in the same direction because here on
the other side of the arm it's pushing
upwards so they're not going to cancel
out they're both going to reinforce and
the this whole coil is going to be
turning in this direction right here
it's going to be moving up out of your
video screen here it's going to be
moving down into your video screen now
what happens so the I'm going to try to
not run out of time either so it's going
to start rotating so the left hand side
is going to go below the page the right
hand side is going to be above the page
I want to draw some perspective that's
why I'm just drawing it bigger so maybe
it looks like that maybe the my circuit
starts to look like that and I'll redraw
my axis of rotation so this is my axis
of rotation another way I drew it this
part of the axis of rotation is still in
the plane of our video but this part of
the coil is you can imagine it popping
out I wish you had 3d glasses on it's
popping out of your screen this part is
going into your screen right and the
current is still going in the same
direction current is going in that
direction they're going in that
direction there so using the same
right-hand rule on this side of the wire
the magnetic field is going to be
exerting a net downward force but the
torque is actually going to be less
right because our actual arm moment arm
distance is going to be like I want to
draw it with some perspective it's going
to look something like that right so
it's going to be going to the left and
behind the page while the torque is
still just into the page so you would
actually take the component of the
torque that's perpendicular so there's
some component the torque that's
actually perpendicular I don't to
confuse you too much but you could
imagine the the torque lessens even
though the net magnetic force is the
same the component of that force is
perpendicular
that's perpendicular to your moment arm
that lessens so there's still going to
be some torque that's going to be
causing it to rotate downwards in that
direction and sorry you know what I drew
this wrong here right we're pushing up
on the right hand side we're pushing
down on the left hand side so the
direction is going to be like that right
pushing up on the right hand down on the
left hand so you're still going to be
doing the same thing here you're going
to be pushing up here we're going to be
pushing up directly out of the page
directly out of the page but that's not
completely perpendicular to the to the
moment arm so some so the component that
is perpendicular it's actually creating
rotational torque that's going to be a
little less and then you can imagine
that all the way to the point the coil
is going to keep rotating at a smaller
width smaller torque and at some point
you'll be looking at it head-on so I can
just draw it like a straight line right
you can imagine this arm is on top and
this arm is behind it and at this point
what's going to happen all of the
magnetic force on this top arm is going
to be popping up right it's going to be
popping up out of your page but it's not
going to be providing any torque because
it's not perpendicular anymore to the to
your moment arm and likewise on the
bottom on the bottom behind this if you
could visualize this it would be
exerting a net downward force and that's
also not going to be helpful but maybe
there has some angular momentum so the
the wire will still rotate but then when
it still rotates what's going to happen
and this is where I'll leave you with a
little bit of a conundrum actually I
don't want to go over the YouTube limit
so I'm going to continue this in the
next video and I'll show you the
conundrum see you soon